bonjour et bienvenue dans ce soap
science consacrée aujourd'hui au
terrifiant gaz de schiste pourquoi
terrifiant parce que parce que tout le
monde dans la peur alors que ça doit
être super l'effrayant à gaz de schiste
non on va peut-être déjà commencé par
dire ce que c'est un gaz de schiste
avant de le qualifier d'effrayant 1dans
gaz de schiste il y assiste c'est à dire
une roche qui se débite en feuillets
comme de l'art d'oise et il n'ya gaz un
gaz combustible que l'on trouve à grande
profondeur dans le sous-sol ici d'un
processus géologiques complexe le gaz de
schiste est donc un gaz naturel comme le
méthane en fait il s'agit même d'un
hydrocarbure un combustible fossile au
même titre que le charbon le pétrole ou
le bikini
cela fait très longtemps que recherchent
des hydrocarbures en france mais les
quelques gisements découverts n'ont pas
permis une exploitation suffisamment
rentable sur la longueur par contre on
pourrait trouver du gaz de schiste un
belle quantité dans les gisements de
charbon du nord pas de calais en
lorraine ou autour de saint-etienne
là il ya 320 millions d'années
s'étendent à une forêt marécageuse
immense de presles de fougères
arborescentes parcouru d'insectes et
d'autres bestiole géante ainsi que des
tout premiers amphibiens les cycles
d'innovation régulière et de
recouvrement de ces marécages déflorée
par du sable puis leur régénération à
préchac submersion sans cesse pendant
des millions d'années ont conduit à la
formation de filons de roches très
rigides en carbone les veines de charbon
qui furent teyssou encore aujourd'hui
exploités par liminaire de ces régions
la nature même de ces roches leur
richesse en carbone alem aspirer le nom
de la période halak à la sauce ont formé
le carbonifère on trouverait aussi les
gaz de schiste dans les mares noir du
jurassique inférieur vieille de 150
millions d'années et qui affleure
surtout dans le larzac et les alpes mais
en fait ce mardi noir sont représentés
partout dans le sous sol français en
particulier en touraine autour de paris
et dans la vallée du rhône
elle était à l'origine une vase épaisse
et puante qui se déposer au fond d'une
lagune ou barbeau terre et mouret
plésiosaures et autres reptiles marins
ainsi que des ammonites sdb les neet par
milliers
l'un des milieux et continental l'autre
et marin mais qu'est ce que ces deux
environnements d'y passer
comme pour avoir produit le même gaz de
schiste assez leurs couleurs le noir une
couleur du à la pourriture et à la
décomposition sous l'action des
bactéries la matière organique
principalement végétale qu'elle soit
faite de fougères géantes ou d'algues va
dégager des gaz nauséabonds comme le
sulfure d'hydrogène ou le méthane et
c'est ce dernier qui donnera après
quelques millions d'années passées en
sous sol notre gaz de schiste web à ses
juges du gaz de matières en
décomposition qui est très vieux quoi
c'est exactement comme le gaz naturel
faut creuser pour en avoir je mens pas
pourquoi on lui donne un nom différent
alors il ya le gaz naturel qui est
gentil et puis le vilain gaz de schiste
khemaicia ordre mais c'est quoi cette
façon de perdre et nos différents tout
ça pour faire peur aux gens et non la
différence avec les autres gaz naturel
réside dans le fait que là où les autres
hydrocarbures s'échappe naturellement
des strates géologiques et les ont vu
naître pour forcer envolé vers l'autre
et sierre n'a pour remonter vers une
autre roche plus poreuses et donc un peu
plus accueillante les gaz de schiste eux
sont contenues dans d'anciennes argile
qui se sont durcies à très grande
profondeur
la différence est que cette roche
retient le gaz car elle est imperméable
et possessive la bougresse elle ne veut
pas laisser partir son petit gaz de
schiste et lui laisser vivre sa vie
ailleurs dans une autre strate
géologique comme son cousin le gaz
naturel
du coup par définition le gaz de schiste
se distingue des autres gaz naturel car
il est prisonnier de sa roche mère
contenus dans des poches qui sont en
fait de grosses bulles de gaz soit à
part le gaz
il n'y a pas grand-chose qui t'intéresse
les mineurs du siècle dernier connaissez
bien incertain gaz de schiste qu'ils
appelaient le grisou creusant les roches
du carbonifère à la lumière de bougies
et rencontrer parfois une poche le
grisou un gaz de schiste bien évidemment
hautement inflammable et alors c'était
le coup de grisou
mme ouattara zana va pas tomber doit pas
tomber tu veux tu veux dire que le gaz
de schiste en fait ça fait super
longtemps qu'on le connaît alors là oui
au moins deux dossiers
c'est pourquoi alors pourquoi on les
exploite pas depuis tout ce temps
comment ça se fait qu'on se pose
seulement la question que maintenant
d'une parce qu'avant on aurait pas de
problème de pénurie de pétrole et de
deux parce qu extraire le gaz de schiste
retenu des centaines de mètres sous
terre ça demande des efforts techniques
on n'était pas capable de fournir à
l'époque
ah oui la fameuse fracturation
hydraulique et oui pour percer les
bulles de gaz il a fallu inventer
différentes techniques et celle qui a
été retenue est celle qui consiste à
envoyer de l'eau et des habitudes sous
pression dans les couches de schiste
pour fracturer la roche est ainsi percer
les bulles qu'elle contient et libérer
le gaz
alors si maintenant c'est comment
l'exploiter quel est le problème le
problème c'est que l'eau et les additifs
ce mélange en profondeur avec les métaux
lourds et les hydrocarbures contenus
dans les schistes
ces polluants risquerait d'atteindre la
nappe phréatique c'est à dire nos
réserves d'eau potable située plus près
de la surface
quel problème la nappe phréatique est
situé plusieurs dizaines de mètres au
dessus l'eau ne peut pas être
contaminées directement via calais c'est
l'eau polluée au fond n'ont pas
justement non c'est impossible
le problème c'est qu'au fond la colonne
de terre au dessus des schistes fait
régner une terrible pression et les
polluants au lieu de rester en bas comme
le voudrait la loi de la gravité sont
expulsés et remonte le long du tuyau
tuyaux qui justement travers cela
phréatique a alors il faudrait donc être
chez elle cette tuile au cetiom et faire
des bassins car cette eau il faudrait la
stocker qui la dépolluer et tout ça
coûte cher
en théorie si toutes ces précautions
sont prises et que l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste est bien fait il ne
devrait pas y avoir de problème pour
l'environnement
à part peut-être l'apparition de
quelques dérives d'un paysage au pas
beaucoup plus les éoliennes d'ailleurs
mais bien faire ça coûte des sous
et les groupes pétroliers ne sont pas
connus pour leur altruisme quand il
s'agit de mettre la main à la poche
c'est dommage car notre sous sol est
riche en gaz de schiste et son
exploitation permettrait de rééquilibrer
un peu la balance commerciale et de
créer des emplois nouveaux dans les pays
développés les gaz de schiste comme les
autres gaz naturel brûlant aussi
beaucoup mieux que le pétrole ou le
charbon et leur combustion plus complète
laisse échapper moins de résidus dans
l'air ce qui les rend
proportionnellement plus efficaces et
moins polluants que les autres
hydrocarbures
enfin exploiter le gaz de schiste dans
un pays développés c'est autant de gaz
de schiste qui ne seront pas exploitées
ailleurs dans un pays où la législation
trop souples ou encore la corruption
serait autant d'invitations à la
négligence et au laxisme face à la
sécurité de l'environnement
et oui elle change en conclusion la
théorie veut que l'exploitation du gaz
de schiste par fracturation hydraulique
puisse être parfaitement sûr et maîtrisé
si elle est bien faite et elle
constituerait alors un coup de pouce non
négligeable à l'emploi surtout pour les
géologues
on pourrait aussi envisager d'exploiter
le gaz de schiste autrement mais les
techniques alternatives sont pour
l'instant moins efficace ou encore
expérimental de la recherche est donc
encore à faire dans ce domaine pour les
géologues
ça c'est la théorie mais en pratique il
faut faire les choses dans les règles et
proprement et tant que bien faire ne
sera pas rentable et bien ce sera pas
gêné en plus il ne faut pas oublier qu'à
exploiter les gaz de schiste ce n'est
que perpétré l'utilisation des
hydrocarbures comme source d'énergie
primaire source qui de toute façon on
finira bien par se tarir
enfin même si l'utilisation des gaz de
schiste pour se chauffer et toutes
proportions gardées moins polluantes
qu'eric du charbon ou du fioul
il n'en reste pas moins que cela demeure
une source d'énergie non renouvelable et
génératrice de gaz à effet de serre qui
accélère donc encore et toujours le
réchauffement de notre planète se lancer
aujourd'hui dans l'exploitation d'un
nouvel hydrocarbures quel qu'il soit
n'est donc certainement pas le plus
gentil des gestes à faire pour préserver
notre environnement
oui frakture without you we find the
world from the sea soleil